[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté devant nous encore une fois un
tableau superbe que ces jeux le ses
fruits avec des couleurs merveilleuses
tous ces produits tout frais oui pour
nous gâter une fois de plus avec tout ça
via nos bouteilles à une bouteille qui
n'a creed
l'aquitaine c'est lucy lucy selanne
orient c'est la normandie c'est un
mélange de norman vie de sud ouest et
vous allez voir que ça va être beau
regarder parce que l'art et du cidre là
j'ai une vieille éthique est un
artisanat 8 d'aigre de framboises cet
excellent et bien leurs impôts de granby
la gelée de vin du médoc alors on va
mais marié lemay 2 et la normandie le
médoc un nomade et le sud tout tout lire
l'avis d'un grand goûter hier voilà en
fait alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de nous faire pour célébrer
ce mariage
bon alors on va commencer par les
magrets parce que c'est ce qui est le
plus long à cuire ne vous faites 4,7
avec les magrets des magrets aussi dreux
et on va faire du jambon des jambons des
aldudes chau giang vinh et au vinaigre
de framboise au vinaigre de framboise
alors c'est ce fameux jambon d'une
vallée des pyrénées une race qu'on a
retrouvée c'est très beau cochon qui ont
la tête en arrière train pour parler les
gammes en noir et le mieux tout rose que
c'est vivre en liberté et le jambon mais
ça les niches formidable alors qu'est ce
qu'il faut comme un grillon repassons
tout ça va le faire on va recommencer
alors il nous faut du cidre il nous faut
du bon vinaigre il nous faut de la
ventrèche enouf otage les deux grosses
de vin médiocre des pauvres de
l'échalote il nous faut de la crème de
la crème
liquide pardon du beurre des magrets
bien entendu et du jambon la salade
c'est pour faire joli et là sinon tu vas
vous m'avez dit qu'on aurait peut-être
un secret oui bien sûr si tout va bien
ce dans le temps vous inquiétez pas la
supposition pour vous c'était le bonheur
du pauvre 19e siècle puis et maintenant
ça fait presque voleurs de richaud mais
en attendant on commence vous avez dit
part dans les magrets au cidre heures
comment fait-on mais éviterait face ils
voulaient me nettoyer un petit peu ma
planche je vais commander le pavé vous
parlez un joli longueur je sais des
broderies cialis refait des progrès et
on a eu des chefs je suis à présent on
avait des fréquentations là ils ont
allumé un vocabulaire mondaine qui ont
élargi votre vocabulaire là j'en ai
besoin vous pourriez la retire le leur
aussi jeu c'est bon on va vous barrez ce
m'agresse si je parle malgré genre à
dire que vous enlevez ce qu'ils grattent
tous les grains je vais voir un petit
peu l'anti comme leader indépendantiste
à gauche voilà voilà je vais le salé le
poivre et
assez généreusement comme toujours bon
non qu il faudrait comme il faut et je
vais le mettre dans ma voile très chaude
chaude hop voilà et la cuire et pendant
ce temps on va s'occuper du jambon
panneautique maïté vous croyez que ce
sera clair dont les deux recettes à la
fois bien sûr parce que alors que la
compagnie vous bien c'est très facile
vous allez voir vous avez coupé maïté de
très belles tranches de jambon là elles
sont épaisses ou pas trop
mitigés comme on dit chez nous ni mince
n'ai trouvé personne à la mesure soit
très bien parti pour les pistes vous les
mettez d'outils à la poêle non alors le
magret et cuit donc là j'ai fait
chauffer la poêle je vais me préparer
mon fond de sauce alors c'est original
et vous allez voir du gras de jambon
tout cela ce gérant des banques
remboursent qui est le plus simple c'est
pas cher pas des gaspillages au revoir
faut-il avoir le beau jambes au numéro
balles trouvées demander un petit peu de
gras shell rocher va vous en donner
voilà on va lui couper là comme ceux ci
et comme la poêle et très chaude il va
assez rapidement au que oui
ça grésille déjà
bon la faille 1 et après l'or après je
vais y mettre leur remonter un petit peu
manga voilà je vais y mettre à cuire
dans ce jus mon échalotes vous en avez
déjà un peu qu'ils aient préparé je vous
dis bon
là ça fait beaucoup mais n'te et ne vous
est versé dans la non violence on va lui
mais l'orque revanche l'autre aux
enquêteurs pendant la panne vous faites
griller tout ça je fais cuire tout ça
pendant que ça cuit et je vais baisser
mon gas parce que ça brûle et oui
s'enfuir non malgré qui vous paraît à
point oui et je vais me mettre dans
l'assiette oui voilà et je vais le faire
notre île est toujours dans notre fou ne
m'en fous voilà
la pâte cuite ni revenir au chaud et
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant il a l'art et la science on
n'avait pas les ressources pour le
magret on va d secure tout ceci je pense
que vous utilisez le cidre oui avoue
d'ouvrir la bouteille nous donne une
bonne
il faut pas faire de bruit on y loue pas
attention et projecteurs mesdames
[Musique]
il vient aux tirs au but toujours
5 bis je l'aimais graisseuses ayé c'est
merveilleux bon alors là on le met dans
la paroisse déglacer la poêle de
l'avesnois l'un avec le tube
on armée pas trop merci quand même avoir
la sienne à ces embarras le reste ce
soir une fille rebouché bien faire le
bon choix mais on a bien travaillé et
avec nos morceaux de gras de jambon et
les chercheurs le lien d'accès aussi un
petit peu de vinaigre vinaigre de
framboise je peux vous l'ouvrez parce
que c'est moins dur principe voilà si
gentille très bien très bien ce petit là
et lorsque vous pouvez observer
et là dessus qu'on va la laisser comme
ça où ça va donner on va y mettre un
petit peu de crème fraîche
l'église beaucoup de crème fraîche et
durcir
ils vont ainsi
que vous allez laisser réduire aussi ça
tout doux soir à bien mélanger tous et
notre jambon il était encore
complètement cru vous l'avez oublié mais
normal heureuse je vais le poil et vous
la passe gmail tranche la up voilà dans
une femme arrêtée dès rafraîchir et
chaude aller retour oui parce que ça il
faudra que soit requiem oui voilà oh ça
va tu oublies termine bien et ça y est
quoi voilà alors devons nous donner la
seat hausse très mignonne votre mignonne
on préfère ça l'humanité se trouve que
c'est une recette facile hein on rentre
à la maison on est c'est une tranche de
jambon et le petit mozart est passé je
voulais faire pour l'améliorer la
chevalerie je sors tout ceci or j'ai
terminé gaz parce que ça va mal joué
mais brûlé et on recouvre cette source
regardez moi cette étrange
voilà
avec de vinaigre de riz salade échalotes
et les gras de jambon c'est pas bon ça
mais ça doit être délicieux sur tout
mais on devra attendre le bout des mains
non parce qu'on va faire finir les
maquerelles dès que vous allez vous
servir avec les magrets des formes de
normandie d'aquitaine nous avons même
s'il elle sait vous bien sûr à 100 a
célébré les noces la normandie de
l'aquitaine à les y voilà enfin de cidre
réduit et voilà et c'est tout simplement
voilà et on va les laisser cuire réduire
comme il faut on va surveiller
les pommes sont cuites jeu prom a été
happé par même qu'elles sont très bien
très dur est derrière ensuite alors je
lui mettre un petit peu de gelée de vin
de médor de vins du médoc elle nous
sommes en train de consommer les noces
de la normandie et de l'aquitaine voilà
exactement souhaitons là c'est beaucoup
de bonheur oh là là et beaucoup de
chance ensemble voilà alors ça s'est
fondu je vais me pousser un petit peu
mais pomme oui et je vais sortir non
malgré qu'ils se trouvent dans mon four
et qui n'est pas complètement cuit qui
n'est pas complètement cuit et qui va
finir de cuire à la poêle à jouer le
maître ici voilà là il est l'hôte et
génère cette fois ci le dessert était
jolie la côte et voilà et je vais
dresser mon plat
c'est pas beau ça superbe et surtout ses
traits à pétition très bien alors on
peut y aller oui bien sûr mais très bien
je vais le laisser je dois remettre des
pommes
ce qui laisse au maghreb petite mine de
blues de plus
voilà là et hop je vais le porter l'âge
de la poêle pour le bien être
et regarder voir ça si c'est beau
ça doit être bon surtout mieux sur terre
rose et un peu non bien sûr la charge
chichis
combien de cendres un bond de 36 brevin
de médoc
intimement uni qui demandent mieux pour
le meilleur et pour le pire à la voile
ont deux plats la tranche de jambon au
vinaigre de framboise le maghreb normes
oriakhi teint et maintenant quoi à l'art
sur la reprise qu'on va vous faire tout
de suite des petits oiseaux dans leur
berceau au mann heat et des petits
oiseaux c'est à dire 10
mai c'était le plat de 2 3 fois nous
autrefois on peut dépendre de terre
c'est-à-dire n'avait pas la télévision
oui et puis il fallait bien occuper le
soir et alors dans la journée cet enfant
dans la famille oui et nous étions très
heureux alors le soir dans la journée il
fallait aussi que mes frères s'occupe il
a tapé des petits oiseaux trappe si on
avait il faut pas avoir ce débat
intervient sont malades et me voilà et
le son en maman voulait préparer elle
nous faisait une pomme de terre comme
ceci s'il personnes voilà c'est le
berceau et nous mettez du sel un petit
peu de poivre dans la pomme de terre
elle prenait les petits oiseaux alors on
en est et suivant la pomme de terre et
de gros traits à tremper dans la m mais
elle nous gâter les embêter et puis pour
améliorer l'ordinaire on avait la chance
d'avoir un cochon oui donc qu'on avait
de la ventrèche tout en étant port on
était très riche un de couper un bon
morceau de petites ventrèche comme ça
voilà alors bien fine oui je vais la
déco années
et voilà alors voyez on était pauvres
mais on était heureux parce qu'on avait
tout ce qu'il y avait de meilleures et
on n'était pas couillon parce que on
savait faire la cuisine et on savait
bien avec de rien on a commandé tout
quelque chose de beurre ajouter les
garçons de la famille qui plus mais tous
ces tout petits 3 non non ce n'est plus
mais mieux nous a trompés ils nous
attraper en jouant et voilà on met ces
oiseaux là dedans elles sont versées on
recouvre la pomme de terre
voilà et on a été dans la sambre
alors on regarde et on se marie ces
inquiétudes la première et on sera mangé
tandis que nous on va la mettre dans le
four on n'a pas la cendre alors voilà et
on va la mettre fou une demi heure à peu
près
voilà on va l'attendre
le petit oiseau d'or dans son berceau
maïté voilà et ça ça me rappelle des
souvenirs 51 en arrière 50 on arrive
alors les enfants d'aujourd'hui devant
la télévision ils sont pas beaucoup plus
heureux parce que là qu'est ce qu'on
s'amuse et qu est ce qu ont discuté
entre nous on était tous entre nous
devons limiter et c'est à celui qui les
mangent le plus beau on se raconter des
choses extraordinaires en même temps et
on était tous tous tous ensemble au
coeur de la forêt l'honneur mais je
crois qu'on vous a donné deux jolies
recettes traditionnelles mais en plus
j'espère on vous a donné un peu de rêve
je vous en souhaite beaucoup au revoir
bientôt bon appétit à bientôt
[Musique]